here's so obviously with these
developments how much money do you
typically need to do one of these deals
okay so it depends on how much you can
you can get on finals so like with the
Lincoln project I've bought that cash
built it cash my own money right we did
that together yeah so that was just
money in if we'd wanted to go down the
bridging rope we could off we've are
because of our track history it's easier
for us to get bridging than sum so we
would have probably put in 40 percent on
the land which would have been I don't
know maybe 100 grand and then the actual
building project we would have
definitely been able to finance again at
least sixty percent sometimes you can
get a hundred percent development caught
with finance so you don't need a lot I'd
say to do a big deal you're probably
talking six figures but you don't need
to be your money because you see when
you're doing when you're doing bridging
finance on a big deal the money that you
do need to put in it can be private
investors money so it doesn't you don't
actually need any money but the reason I
don't talk loads about development on my
videos and say oh you can do if no money
you can buy a piece of land and build
houses with no money is because it is
risky if you don't know what you're
doing and if you're leveraging yourself
to the max using other people's money
and the project doesn't work it could
literally put you into a what's the word
AB right now you could have a you could
have a mental breakdown of stress with
development if you do it wrong and you
don't know what you do I know people
thought pubs and they've you know we're
gonna do it up when they split into
flats but it's been it's been a fantasy
romance thing with their wife but
they've struggled with the planning and
then the builders of charge three times
the amount they thought and then they've
it's been down vide and they've lost so
much money and there's other people's
money into it and it's like yes there
are stress to their eyeballs and lose
everything and lose their reputation and
it's just it can be swear as what I
teach I mean I do teach development and
anticipate an advanced level but you
know and BRR and stuff like that but
when you're buying a small house
it's like you put it in twenty grand
and to some people
a lot and that could be stress step
still but if you're buying a house it's
residential 20 grand mentor now there's
like a lot less that can go wrong in one
sense or if it does the consequences
aren't gonna [ __ ] you you're not
really lying on there's lots of factors
to rely on so for example ribs Woodhouse
obviously we got they that's the castle
for anyone that Duke the castle yes
obviously born in the first place then
we've got spend millions doing or doing
it up
I mean over over - mm yeah is what it
will be about - 2.1 2.2 mil on time we
finished but that can obviously change
because then they can find problems
which so can go up and there's a lots
and then it's like water them to the N
value gonna be exactly as it happens
we've got a good deal there's a nice big
cushion so we're gonna be okay yeah
we've got a lot of profit in there so
even if it's more and even if it's yeah
exactly but if you don't know what
you're doing and you do calculate it
wrong and people tend to calculate it
they tend to assume it's gonna be better
than it is right it's so funny because
people think I am such a negative person
when they when they do business with me
because it's weird because I'm so
positive property investing is easy
anyone can be financially free you can
do it you know take action that's my
message and that's completely correct
but then when I'm actually doing
development deals of construction or a
lot more than I am I'm so much more
negative than you are yeah I am
absolutely worst case boy they call me
Samuel worst case leads because I'm so
negative because I've had so many
problems and I've had so much go wrong
and I've been so excited so many times
and it's not worked out so that no we're
not doing deals even in business in
general
I am so negative that's where I am
negative not negative but I do not count
my chickens to last don't know if
there's a deal going ahead until it's
actually done I don't even get excited
about it know people say to me like hey
why you no because it hasn't actually
actually gone through the mat last
second I know until you got the keys
never bees until you got the gold they
have not been sold like all this stuff
and so many people as well pull out it's
crazy how many properties fall out of
bed if you buying something it falls
like before before you buy it but then
if you develop something you've built
something and you sell
yeah if you've got a buyer lined up
until you've completed they could pull
out any minute hmm and they do and they
do like it's not like it's hypothetical
they could but they it happens a lot a
lot even if they've bought it from
auction off yeah sometimes people would
just say you know what forget the 10%
how to keep it so you cannot rely on it
so you just got to be so careful and
when you celebrate celebrate hard and I
celebrate my life every day but just I'm
so negative and I'm so and when I see
these these newbie investors and don't
get me wrong I'm so positive and
supportive around people and building
people up and my job is to empower
people because here's what a lot of
people don't they they that they
disguise themselves as being
conservative and professional and and
and constructive and all this but
actually they just want people to fail
and and and and they will say they'll
make it look so hard and make things so
difficult when pooping on people's
dreams because they want they don't want
people to succeed all I want people to
succeed but at the same time I've got
the experience to know you've gotta be
conservative and people sometimes people
bring me deals or I'm doing this I've
even people on the Academy I've got this
deal I'm gonna reevaluate this and I'm
like pull out I had it the other day I
had it with Amelia Amelia's mom Amelia's
mom came around my house for some dinner
and she said I'm behind this house I'm
really excited it's gonna be amazing I
was on this gray I said let me have a
look at it I look today and I said to
her I think you should pull out and I
knew that that wouldn't that was not
what she wanted to hear and I didn't
want to say it because I love being the
bearer of good news I don't like bad
news I don't want people to bring bad
news to me I don't want to be bad news
to people I'm a good newsman but I know
that the deal was risky and I knew that
there was a very good chance that the
value would come back low that the bit
and I could just see that him I could
you see that it wasn't quite what she
thought it was or at least probably
wasn't and I said to look it's not
terrible deal but I don't think it's
what you think it is and I would walk
away and she was just like and then
she's all right she's doing it a joint
venture partner I don't want to let him
down there I think I'll do it just
because no one hurt him down I said
listen man here we
all that down for deals yeah that's what
I said I said his it here's what's gonna
happen
I said over the next eight months if you
go ahead and I told her the story the
bill is gonna do this and then this is
gonna happen and then you pick you out
my just what's gonna be really stressed
and you gonna argue about this and then
the value is going to come at this and
then deliver and in the end it was like
you've made five grand profit for a
moment be better off working in Tesco's
and she was just like oh and then she's
like I want to let me think about how
I'm gonna tell him and let me I said
give me you phone she went you're gonna
call him I said yeah no yeah because I
you know I mean so but that's me trying
to see her succeed
I never said now let me help you find
another deal yeah isn't just in there
because obviously we we teach and I'm
the massive believer
well I sorry this podcast is so good
it's going on my channel no it's not I'm
a massive believe in positive it so yeah
and about being positive it's so
interesting is we're looking obviously
being negative in certain situations as
well so how would you say well when
when's the time to positive and winter
time to be negative okay so I think
being positive is saying that I can do
it it's going to be done I'm gonna make
money I'm going to succeed being
negative is about being realistic with
how you're gonna do it so okay I'm gonna
say you could say I'm gonna become
financially free this year I wouldn't
say if I said no you know be realistic
that would be horrible I would say yes
you can
yes you will but then if I ever deal
it's not great but it's been negative
about the deal itself I mean not even
negative just being conservative but not
being conservative on yourself and what
you can achieve I think there's a big
difference yeah yeah
I think there's a massive difference I'm
just trying to think of a way of
conveying it so that people don't know
samuel says it's good to be negative and
trying this app I am allergic to
negativity yeah right
if you've been negative about yourself
and about what you can achieve or being
negative I'm not gonna say oh that deal
doesn't work therefore it doesn't work
therefore no deal can work I'm gonna say
that di that's too risky has to
conservative let me find a better deal
let me find a a more profitable deal I'm
not gonna just give up I'm just gonna
find a better way and I'm not going to
do it was I'm scared
believe totally believe you can do it
but don't I think the big one for me
where I'm really I'm not I just I just I
just assume that every deal could fall
out of bed although this this caption
should be called Samuel Leeds is
negative in real life there yeah I think
so
and then people were like what he's
negative in real life is this a is this
a hate video no this is a real videos
over brother hate but sometimes people
get so shot though about me when they
because because because I am my brand is
positivity and I am positive but I think
some people do get it mixed up mm-hmm
yeah and it's I totally agree with
everything you've everything you said
about he's a really interesting balance
there because I have fired accountants
for being too negative you don't want
you do you do want me no no no no you do
want the conservative really may be
negative it's the wrong word I don't
think your negative is the wrong word
you want them not for the title no not
for the title let's get those clicks
baby could you click some positive no
what I'm saying is if someone is
negative and they focus on the problems
that's a bad thing but then just look in
the best case and worst case and making
an educated decision to step forward
mm-hmm you know there is there must be a
difference then yeah some okay so um
with the problem is the word really is
you worry you if you want to say realist
but people disguise that as negative
people say then I'm just a realist
I sometimes and look on the negative
side for a autumn a positive outcome
yeah so someone that's got negative if I
if someone's got negative energy like
that's why I fired a negative accountant
they'll just come in at a negative
energy mmm
hey dude fine I don't want that yeah I
want I'm awesome
I'm great yes you're great let's have a
look at you deals all that deal is a bit
too risque
I think you can do better yeah that's
what I'm talking about
yeah I know I don't think it's gonna
work there is a difference and there's
what's the difference but I think you
some know quite well in terms of
believing in yourself
I believe I come in finds you afraid I'm
gonna find a great deal
and that isn't great enough but it's
it's been blind doesn't it it's been
blind to a deer because you're masking
it ah it'll all work out for the best no
money you've gotta be smart as where
you'll be educated well you gotta know
what you do it hmm
and then be positive in just believe in
yourself but then you have got to see I
do believe in faith I'd say it's a hard
one then isn't it it's a hard one
because so explain that you believe in
favor so how does that work do you
believe in just thinking ah it's gonna
work out for the best
yeah but when it comes to valuers and
builders nope
it's so interesting and we just talk
about it all day we could and it's just
it's just bringing in logic and
experience and sales questioning let's
say then someone watching this and they
are just getting started in development
yeah well in property yeah and they're
thinking you know what I've got 100
grand yeah and plus in the bank I'd love
to get into development because the
great thing about development is you put
your money and you get it all back and
you make a profit Yeah right assuming
that you do correctly and these
sometimes make a very big profit like
I'm talking a million pound plus yeah
now what could they do I mean you
mentioned the people in you get people
that invest with you so how does that
work let's say okay so the few things
that you need you need good deals you
need good finance and you need a good
power team yeah they're the three things
that you need if you can find good deals
and you can finance the deals and then
you've got a good power team that's
that's kind of the keys to success in
development to find a good deal again
you need three things you need to know
what am i buying this this project for
this property this piece of land
whatever was my purchase price
what is the development cost and then
what is the N value finding those three
figures is all you need to succeed
because if you know you're gonna buy it
for 500 grand and then you're gonna
spend 500 grand on it and you're going
to put a million in but in the end value
is going to be 1.5 million then you know
you've made a five hundred thousand
pounds profit so obviously obviously
gross gross so so that's what you need
to that's what you need to look at those
three figures finding those two figures
is hard you need Ric's valuers to give
you the N value if you're doing a big
deal
you need builders to give you a
breakdown of the works and you need to
survey it's predicted that they're
actually going to stick to you need to
make sure that the quote is itemized
that there's penalties if they go over a
time scale and stuff so that's the bit
that takes that takes work so but
effectively that is the breakdown of of
what you need to succeed in development
okay so how do you get started
yeah how much money do you need so okay
it depends if you've got no experience
in property whatsoever I what I
generally teach you start with small
deals or joint venture with someone on a
big deal that is very trustworthy and
and knows what they do and has got all
the facts and figures that you need
because generally speaking you're gonna
make a lot of mistakes on your first
deal thank God some of these big deals
thank God I got a decade experience in
property my first deal is a small house
it was like a hundred grand house I
split into four rooms
- do you went well didn't it anyway it
did go well but that wasn't my first
house and then I started buying lots and
lots of houses and then slowly getting a
bit bigger and then I you know I'm gonna
try a you know a 6 bed license take some
oh I need planning I know ok and now I'm
gonna do a bit of a project in the B of
do it and then I've slowly built but so
I want to you know I've also got
brilliant team around you as well
brilliant tip yeah which is really
important yeah because you've got the
Flair and the knowledge you've got
feeling I've got the the big picture I'm
the visionary I know I can do most
people's jobs but then I've got
specialists as well yeah yeah but if you
start if you've got like a hundred
rounding you starting out and you don't
know anything about property probably
don't do a million pound project and
finance yourself up to the hill unless
you're Jay being with someone like you
what if you came in with me but I don't
drive you people easily know because the
last thing I want is stress in my deals
I want as least hassle as possible and
the people that are gonna bring me
hassle they're going to be tenants
tenants bring hassle so I don't want
lots of tenants that's why I don't want
people systemic how many houses do you
own it's a bad question
ask me a better question like how much
money are you making because people
think it's about only lots of houses I
know people are owned over
houses and make no profit that I have a
hundred houses that 100 headaches hmm
and they bought them in bad areas their
bad times they're in negative equity the
mortgage is barely covered by the tenant
it's just but then that's not a bragging
right for me I don't even want to buy
hundreds of houses I don't make a lot of
money so I want to slowly this year I
only wanted I only really this year when
I did my video they said that I said I
don't wanna do two deals this year I can
make a million pound profit a deal I'm
alright with two deals yeah so I could
use that money to buy a hundred houses
I don't want an extra hundred houses and
the reason a lot hassle is because time
is money so and it takes just as much
effort to do a small deal as a big deal
so just to having to go view a house in
Liverpool for me I'm like well how many
thousands of pounds have I lost to
happen to do that trip to gonna view it
compared to the reward which is how much
I'm not going to make off of this deal
straight away I've lost money because of
the time so if I'm driving to Liverpool
now I don't want to go and look at a
sixty thousand pound house even though
it's gonna make me a twenty five percent
ROI because the trip alone to view that
one house if I'm gonna do the trip I'd
rather for your house is potentially
going to make me a hundred grand
yeah you know so so selling time start
with the smaller Bari furbish refinance
type strategy bet and then build up I
think so because you're gonna make
mistakes on your first deal make
mistakes on the hundred grand house yeah
and make all the mistakes on the little
deals and then slowly build another way
you got hassle so there's hassle with
with tenants there's hassle with
builders you know what's crazy
well you have more hassle with builders
on small projects and I'll tell you why
because when you're dealing with a big
project you can afford to pay big
companies and although you pay big bucks
it's a big company that professional
when you're dealing with a ten ground
refurb on the house and you dealing with
a one-man band and then you gotta get an
electrician in it you've got a book
there's and but when you've got a bigger
project you just afford to pay a project
manager just solve a lot you can afford
to bring in more specialists there's
almost a satyr to waste before it's
almost the same effort you know a big
deal at scale another thing that brings
hassle is stress head joint venture
partners brings hassle because if
someone's gift
one hundred runners their life savings
and their protective over it and then
they give it to you and it's going to be
a 12-month project and every day they're
like how's it going oh my gosh it's
definitely gonna work isn't it it's like
look we've got a contract and we've risk
assess it and if it doesn't work this is
your money's protected rather just use
my own money you know and I got to that
point where I only used my own money and
most strategies that I started off with
which was never use my own money which
is what I preach and I advocate you know
in 2090 nice to persist using my own
money and people were sent queuing up
saying hey can I join Joe hey here
somebody has I didn't even want the
bank's money I was paid I paid off and
loads of my mortgages I had so much
money in 2019 I was handing out money to
people getting a fixed return on
interest and it's only when Grant
Cardone schooled me said EMA you were
they said that I was over the hill
he was also you're over the hill now
you've peaked and I was offended and
then I know I was looking at him and I
was like well you're almost a
billionaire why do you still borrow
people's money because I'm wanting to
grow as big as I can possibly get need
the biggest legacy the impact as many
people as I can I'm thinking he's in his
60s I'm in my twenties he's calling me
over the hill right so now I'm thinking
okay forget this I know what did I do
we financed he even told me to sell he
was like sell all your little houses
dude
that's what makes me all my money yeah
but the stuff you do now the biggest day
so I'm still not quite there
so I've sold quite a lot of little
houses I've refinance the houses that
had mortgages on mostly and I'm now
joining with people but I'm learning
like absolutely loads because back when
you first started you needed leverage
because what may you didn't you a didn't
need to but if you want to grow it still
make sense to I mean I did that video as
well because I would meet people like
very wealthy athletes and sports stars
and pop stars and they'd have a million
quid and let go I'm looking to invest
into a house in London I'm like wow I'm
willing to buy like a house or an
apartment you know maybe an apartment
I'll buy one I'm one million pound
apartment
for a million pounds and went out for
three grand a month all right wall we
call that financially [ __ ] yeah yeah
you know but then I'm kind of not doing
much different myself is very different
yeah than that I'm like leverage yeah
what are you crazy I just wanted to sit
on it and okay yeah but it would yield
me three and a half percent which isn't
bad is it terrible it would yield you
two and a half percent and your return
on investment would probably be around
about 1.5 percent males will leave it in
the back mate it's just terrible
the absolute terrible so now you are
open to JVM yeah yeah I've half David
I'm JB the last six months of JV to
several people but I've just picked one
careful right people relationships yeah
I've got to be the right people people
that come to send me messages or I've
got 10 million in the back let's do
something together I'm just like yeah
yeah yeah whatever but then people I
know I've built relationship with on
there and sometimes if I know who they
are
you just I'm just careful yeah careful
negative skeptical burned wounded rich
happy growing learning
[Music]